good morning believe nation if you are
looking for the best way to stay
motivated in your business I'm going to
share with you a clip from Greg Plitt
that I think will help how to restate
Motor Vehicles 1 get a partner champions
come in pairs of two because they bow
themselves in perfection a partner is
not only an asset to you on the physical
side but also the mental side meaning
when you guys are coming home from work
or something or maybe the wife is just
yelling at you too much and that's give
you driving you into a migraine where
the kids are just you know it's one of
the days you know the boss he's like I
just need to go to the bar or something
you know well if you have a partner you
partner some corner amen buddy Jim you
like do man has had a long day and
everything else and it's not feeling man
like on the gym you know and so you let
him down now
we can all fool ourselves and Barry the
real truth inside of us of why we're not
going right and kid ourselves for
whatever reasons are these excuses I
mean nothing but we'll give them value
give them weight to make us not go so we
can fail when our own account but you
gotta be a really low to fell on some
weights relying on you very few people
do that when you make a commitment a
verbal written commit to somebody you're
me and your word means you mean
something to them when they call you up
and say hey let's go and you like to
mail not into it man I into it Wow so
you're not into it not only affects you
but also affects someone else's state
know what's gonna happen that guy's
gonna pull you into the gym drag you
through the workout even though you were
oh you didn't want to and by expending
that energy at tired state you can come
at it doing since a privately
well you know more found energy like wow
man I got that felt good now you move
back into your problems that you didn't
want to do the jinkers are overwhelming
and you can look at them differently now
I'm sorry you know see the problems with
solutions because your your minds
you're thinking smarter you're thinking
more more of the glass half full set tap
empty no and you'll have find remedies
and solutions those problems makes for a
better day combine that for all of them
good week good month good year also
partners really key because you're going
to have hit you're gonna hit failure
right the partners we have use for
scraps three four reps those are pushing
past failure where you going to feel
that high
you feel that pump you're gonna feel a
lot on top of that you guys are going to
go through the same workout with Keynes
right now person a sa Joe is I'm good at
person B John and say man now not what
you feel like John you feelin it and
John might be like yeah man totally
feeling it and joe cagg well well John
you know what I'm doing wrong yeah I
think you're doing this way let me try
that oh yeah now I feel it so you guys
can get in push and pull off each other
on what is working what isn't working so
you find a mental strength or you like
hey man
Johnny and a I'm not feeling this but
you know what let's see the results as
much um you know what's your diet like
what are you doing well I'm doing this
and doing that and you guys start
comparing each other you know and you
guys are feeding off what is working
what isn't working because you guys are
team partners are essential guys if you
don't a partner you really can't push
yourself past the current limitation
since those Flores reps and failures and
drop sets and anything else to really
get the most bang for the buck okay
partner must be the partner so Greg is
obviously a workout guy a gym guy but
his lesson applies to anything that
you're doing in life anything that
you're doing in your business where
you're struggling to stay motivated it's
especially hard for entrepreneurs
because there's nobody to hold you
accountable right there's nobody who's
saying that you don't have a boss right
you don't have that guy saying hey you
have to get this done by this day if you
don't want to do something you don't
have to do it and that's a dangerous
recipe what I find really helps is to
form either partnership or get a
mastermind group that you can bounce
ideas off of and have people that you
can commit to to say I'm going to get
this done that can hold you accountable
hold your feet to the fire if you don't
actually go and do it
see as entrepreneurs we tend not to do
the things that we have to do tend not
to do the important things the things
that will really help our businesses
grow because they're too uncomfortable
they're too scary and we've convinced
ourselves that we don't really need to
go and do that that's not really going
to impact my business you tell yourself
this story because really you're just
afraid and then you go and do these
other things that aren't so important
that you build up the importance in your
mind you focus your attention on the
wrong thing because it's safe because
it's predictable because you know how to
do it and you avoid doing the big scary
unpredictable things but you need to go
there if you want to build a successful
business and if you're only accounting
to yourself it can be really really
really hard and difficult to push
yourself to give yourself that
motivation to step way outside your
comfort zone and go for those bigger
goals so get someone to help push you
and you can help push them whether it's
a partnership in your business whether
it's joining the mastermind group
whether it's setting up your own
mastermind group I find success with my
online and offline mastermind groups I
can tell you it makes a humongous
difference to keeping you motivated to
help when you go and accomplish your
goals and to help when you build
something that you can be proud of
believe thank you guys for watching my
question of the day today is who helps
keep you accountable in your business in
your life I'm curious
hopefully it's somebody if it's nobody
you can put that down too but leave a
comment below who holds you accountable
and of course if you like this video and
you want to see more don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and the
newsletter thank you for watching
continue to believe go out and have an
amazing day and I hope to see you again
tomorrow to help kick start your day
with another inspirational video for
entrepreneurs